mommy right and I got nowhere the big
house just the cooking working honest
enough then again the number one job
dream of every thirteen to sixteen year
old in America is to be a youtuber and
or an influencer you gotta be up in the
office do rap rap it will be too costly
talk about ownership and leverage KPI
detectors that outdoors average so about
to do a face time now a lot of you do
the 60-second Club and so about the
little gifts and things of that nature
fifty second club is when you post a
comment or that end the hashtag were
just the hash tag on my Instagram post a
lot of people turn on my notifications
on Instagram for that and just it's a
fun little thing I mean a lot of people
like aw you're not hustling cuz you're
part of 60 cycle of them I love when
they do that actually know when you guys
do that but you got to mix fun into
stuff and just like a fun little game
that we're doing I'm actually knew a
little more fun on Instagram do some
more giveaway more cheesy fun I need it
giveaways contests like first one the
notice what colors in the background or
some you know how many of these are you
know what I mean I want to do a little
more of that fun anyway good to be doing
more fun
doing a good read John what's up I'm in
the middle of a good rant so you know
you're important for me to pick this up
I got it I got okay thanks the line so
where was I
and obviously put music all over that
because of another [ __ ] fire in my
life um what I think fun giveaways was
able to talk about you not another thing
yeah so one of the cool things is access
better than t-shirt better than a
thinner than a book is access and what
I'm doing right now is I'm giving access
what we're doing right now is doing a
FaceTime on snapchat so I think one of
the great things to do is to absolutely
be part of 60-second Club to win access
because it's [ __ ] impossible look
like a Christmas tree with it with a
YouTube channel you can go super nation
and be all about jellybeans or you could
be day-in-the-life blog I think at the
end of the day both work I think you
just need to know yourself if you have
something that you're super hardcore
expertise in that you have you have
super hard core expertise in or super
hard core passion well then that's
something that you'd want to talk about
the next 5-10 years then I'm comfortable
with niche but I think people are always
trying to find which one's better and
the truth is or is that it's better
based on the person there's no general
answer it's more predicated on you right
what what feels right to you
how long have you been doing it good you
know what I'm going to say four months
is just not enough time to decide if
this is right or not right keep trying
different things and really if you want
to win as a vlogger you know it's funny
every fifteen-year-old and now every
thirty year old in the world wants to be
an influencer or you know or or a
YouTube celebrity right and the reality
is is if that's true the reason
everybody wants to do that is because
it's a [ __ ] awesome life right and so
if that's true if that's what one wants
I don't understand how people are not
committed to doing it every day for 18
to 24 months before they even begin to
doubt should I jump off this like the
thought of like jumping off early on
something that is so amazing right I
think it's more about you interacting
with them when you have a small
following so you should message a direct
message every single person every single
person watching my vlog right now if
they have 300 or less people following
them on Instagram
tonight they should DM every single
person and say thank you for following
me what are you following me for and is
there anything I can do for you that's
the quickest way to go from 300 to 800
putting out content is the cost of entry
or mec major upside in the game in my
opinion and then you just got to hope
it's interesting entertaining mixed
people escape and educates them
motivates them you know I think the
reason I work is I think I educate
people I think I definitely motivate
people and I think I entertain people I
think that's you know when you think
about the three pillars if you've
actually got I'm sure I probably over
index and motivation and maybe a little
less than entertainment and really
really great in education and so you
know but there's a lot of people that
don't do any of those three things and
that's why nobody [ __ ] watches them
all right
you're welcome
all right that's good the whole thing
from the John call the whole thing aside
you work the place yeah I think much I
think actually it's not like actually I
have a pretty important thing that you
share this with the whole team I think
we actually should go through a period
of time of making the vlog vlog reverb
you know so this now I feel like ready
so for example that was interesting
because I got interrupted this and that
I feel like we can base the whole thing
on like anything I'm doing for one to
four minutes that is unusual I think
should now take more precedence because
we're doing some cracking and so on and
so for me like like an entire episode
around the greenroom dynamics or me
playing me playing bubble hockey with
Justin and then then Tyler you or iris
Justin asking me about being competitive
and the whole things about why I wanted
to crush Justin that I did successfully
crush Justin's face and bubble-hockey
yeah so I think we should all start
challenging ourselves with that and
that's that all of that yeah it's the
whole thing it's all a mental game it's
not much of it it's the operating system
of everything you do I just created for
Chris Bryant from stat which completes
over the last six hours me fire sailing
my entire team and fantasy baseball I'm
setting myself up for next year it just
didn't work out it's just going to work
out
you're right honey that is doing this is
a special special edition of the dangle
rail show I'm so focused in my 20s to
build the empire that I imagine it just
wasn't my driving force as the cliche
would play out for both sides of that
Pamela and I bring it up because I am
concerned that the current conversation
on social media Instagram specifically
around entrepreneurship is so skewed to
champagne bottles models by the Jets
Lambos rare animals and all sorts of
your [ __ ] and nobody's talking about the
truth yeah which is why I did a levy
which is the truth is not [ __ ]
glamorous I realize that I'm being
treated very differently right now by
fifteen to twenty five year old guys and
if I can inspire young men to be better
human beings in the way that men run
through this world that could be a
really quick legacy
[Applause]
[Music]
this is not some sad you know that's
going to be around for a little bit this
is the fundamental shift of how human
beings interact with each other which is
the currency of our lives I don't think
this room including myself actually
understands how big of an opportunity
this is in whatever you care about your
entire life regardless of industry over
the next decade we'll be eaten up by
technology and either you're on the
eating side or you're on the other side
and so we have a little window here I've
been doing my thing for 20 years not
forever but long enough to know this
I've only seen it twice because like
getting electricity this is big [ __ ] and
this is big [ __ ] not only in your
business life but in the dynamics of who
we are as a man thank you thank you take
care
[Music]
you can with patience with everything be
alright you know yeah there's a missing
piece because plug that in and boom I
think I think the one that's really
working for me right now is you're gonna
die it's actually very positive it's
been interesting to see how people
reacted to when I said that
it's just how I think which is like why
do you not maximize instead of worrying
about how all these things are why don't
you enjoy the fact that you actually
have a life and go do something about it
so my big one is you're going to die so
do something about heading to the
airport now
read I promised myself I wouldn't do any
road eyes look five already this year
it's ridiculous well like three years
without three years of that one mmm yeah
[Music]